dude that's crazy that that that mistake
that's a 10 million dollar mistake
[Music]
um andrew what's going on dude i'm are
you pumped to do this i'm really yeah
i'm excited i've worked out this morning
and phil feel good it's a nice sunny day
we had a big dump of snow here which is
actually incredibly rare usually it like
never goes below freezing so uh yeah
it's nice what'd you do
uh no i actually went on my treadmill i
started i it's weird i was kind of
feeling like a little low energy over
christmas and i realized this hadn't
worked out and so i was like i'll take
you know am i eating the right thing am
i doing the right routines am i doing my
gratitude journalism can't relate
what supplements am i taking you've
never had and then i just worked out
yeah
i just realized like working out is all
you need to do
there's a there's a great quote it's in
um this book i was reading called the
body and it basically said like if we
could put in pill form all the benefits
that exercise gives you
you it'll be the it would be the most
successful medicine of all time right
and the whole point of the book was um
it was called the body by bill burst and
i by
bryson i love that book and uh he's just
he's like basically like sleep and
exercise are the cure to most everything
yeah it's crazy i love his writing he's
uh he's great um do we want to get into
this sean yeah let's do it um we did
this last year
and uh i think it was probably my
favorite episode last year we called it
the millie awards we did an awards
ceremony at the end of the year andrew
came on and we did it in 2020 at the end
of the year and i actually went back and
i listened to it which is you know it's
cringy to listen to your own voice
recorded but
it was a really entertaining episode and
we made a bunch of predictions i
actually even kind of noted some of them
down i don't know if you guys saw that
like some of the um
some of the things that we had said last
year
and uh and so we're gonna do it again
and we're gonna try to make this an
annual tradition we'll see how it goes
and uh all right so without further ado
here we are the 2021 milli awards we are
back and uh we got about the way it
works so we got a bunch of different
categories the three of us did our
research did our thinking about who we
think is the winner for each we did not
tell each other did not show each other
so if we have the same answer it's just
coincidence um great minds think alike
and we're going to react to kind of how
each one goes and i have a little side
game here which i'm going to play
as little notepad
i'm just going to kind of take notes of
who i think wins each category in terms
of their answer so we'll see we'll see
who brings the heat uh during this thing
i got sam
i got sean i got andrew and i'll put a
little tally for and i'm the only judge
or you guys can chime in on that but i'm
just going to keep note of how we do for
for this whole episode all right so did
i miss anything sam are we good to go
yeah and we what i'm i all right so i
have up i have two documents i have one
document with like my answers and then
i've got the other document that have
last year's answers and so i think what
we should do
is you can lead and you could say like
the the category and then you could say
here's what last years are right okay so
we'll work all right so we'll start with
uh
we'll start with
uh breakout company so uh this is the
2021 breakout company it's a company
that kind of like exploded wait no billy
of the year is first sean okay you want
to go in the actual order we can go to
the actual order all right so billy of
the year is number one then we do billy
of the week sometimes on
the pod so this is billy of the year it
doesn't have to be somebody who's a new
billionaire but it's just a billionaire
who had a hell of a year last year
sam said chuck feeney who is um
who's check video he's the guy from
blockbuster and all that stuff or that's
somebody else no he's just a he was like
he started a business where they sell
at airports but he gave away free
yeah duty-free but he gave away all of
it giveaways we gave away 10 billion
andrew had mark leonard who's i think
the ceo of constellation software is
that right who's you know maybe uh yeah
you know somebody you respect who runs a
similar playbook to you buys great
companies owns them for a long time very
stealthy secretive guide you shared a
bunch of cool stories about how he keeps
a low profile and then i had eric yuan
who was the ceo of zoom because i
thought zoom sort of saved the world
during the pandemic and let the world
continue to run
and um and so i had eric eric you on so
who do we have for this year we'll start
with sam billy of the year who you got
darmesh the cto and co-founder of
hubspot he came on our podcast sucking
up to your boss
well yeah i mean i guess but he uh he
just had the idea outlook on life and i
think he had an amazing job like he
basically said no one reports to him and
he doesn't report to anyone i think he i
don't know what what's he worth like two
billion dollars whatever hubspot stock
is worth i thought he was pretty amazing
at a good outlook and what was the
outlook that you liked i thought the
most interesting thing about dharmesh is
exactly what you said that instead of i
think so many entrepreneurs are like
okay i'm either all in or i'm all out
and he kind of said you know what i'm
just going to do this stuff i like and
he's kind of a floater like he just kind
of floats around within the company and
i thought that was really cool and he
was nice the thing about darmesh is that
he's nice and he's friendly and he's
calm and i really enjoy that about him
he's not a type a or he is type a and
that he's competitive but he's not like
trying to alpha people he's very
comfortable in his uh all right andrew
who you got billy of the year
so mine it was actually a guy i randomly
met so i was at this cocktail party at a
just a house in my neighborhood and i
was talking to this guy and i started
asking him what he did and he said he
was in the the kind of beverage space
and he started saying names that i kind
of knew like mission hill winery which
is like a big winery up here and anyway
it turns out this guy's worth 8 billion
dollars and he owns a beverage focused
holding company called mark anthony
group this guy named anthony von mandel
and his story is pretty crazy so he
started a little like wine importing
business in vancouver and
uh made enough money to buy a winery
called mission hill took out a ton of
debt the it was like dirt floors had
only a few barrels of wine turned it
around turned into a real solid business
and then he hit it big when he was
trying to diversify and he started a
company called mike's hard lemonade
which i'm sure you guys have heard of
and this is like an insane story like in
the 90s people would have fights in the
liquor store over the last couple
bottles of mike's heart uh it went into
the states
uh and sold by the way
in america we like make fun of people
who drink like it's like a joke like
mike's heart totally well the idea the
idea they had was like men are too
embarrassed to drink coolers so like
let's make a cooler they can kind of not
be too embarrassed to drink
but anyway he ended up
building that into a massive business uh
he ended up also starting white claw a
couple years ago which is like the same
idea but healthy and now they do 1.4 or
sorry 4 billion dollars of revenue uh
last year in 2020 uh and the craziest
thing about this guy is he owns i
believe a hundred percent of the
business and he has no debt because he
had been almost in bankruptcy multiple
times so it was just totally crazy local
entrepreneur who just knocked it out of
the park and i'm obsessed with these
guys who have just like taken a risk
they've done it 100 themselves they
didn't have vcs they didn't have
investors uh so just an amazing story
wow that's a good one that's a good i
didn't realize the mic's hard
the company has mike's heart also does
white claw which is amazing it's
basically a reboot of the similar
concept
um totally okay all right what about you
my billy of the year so i had two all
right so i have um
i have the eye roll one which is elon
musk but it's not for the reason that
most people would think
um as you know one of the maybe top
three slogans of this podcast is bet on
yourself and elon several years ago did
a bet on yourself comp compensation plan
that you guys probably remember i don't
know if everybody knows about this i'll
summarize it and i'm kind of hand waving
through some of the details just to be
quicker about it but basically
tesla at the time i think it was five
years ago was at about a 50 billion
dollar market cap and people the rumor
was elon's gonna leave and he might uh
you know go just focus on spacex
full-time and he had a negotiation with
the board and basically said okay i'll
stay but here's the compensation plan i
want
and he sketched out a plan he said look
you only pay me if i increase
shareholder value yeah no guaranteed
money and he basically did it where
in rough strokes every 50 billion in
market cap they added he would get
another 1 of the company
and so it was at 50 billion so he'd have
to get 100 billion to get anything if he
got to 99 he got nothing
and so he had to get it to 100 to get
any more for all his hard work
and uh i remember there's a great clip
if you go to youtube and you just go you
just you just search for uh elon musk
compensation plan uh you know cnbc
there's this clip of
the anchors making fun of them because
they're like oh yeah and like you know
this plan is it's unprecedented it has
this far-fetched idea that if he could
get over 600 billion
you know elon would get this huge unlock
if he gets to that reward but you know i
think we could safely say like you know
it's never going to happen like you know
why even include that in there
and sure enough this year tesla crosses
all that he hits every single part of
the compensation plan i think it's a
it's now a trillion dollar company uh
and basically the guy called a shot he
bet on himself and uh and hit all of it
so i really like
that like the betting on yourself aspect
of it so that's why i give it to elon
but what was the second one the second
one uh again a little bit of a of an
expected answer but not not for the
reason you think
so vitalik buterin who's the co-creator
of ethereum
he's worth himself probably 1.6 billion
i think as of the based on the like the
value of ethereum today something like
that one or two billion dollars
but he was uh one of the like there's
all these new projects constantly
launching and one of the ways that
projects were
trying to get hype in marketing is that
they would just send some of their
project into vitalik's wallet his public
wallet
and they would say look vitalik holds
our coins so you should too
and then the other thing that they would
say that was the first marketing scheme
people do like and then people fell for
they're like oh vitalik's investing in
this i'll invest in it too but like he
didn't actually invest in it they just
sent it for free just shoved it in his
wallet
the second thing that people were doing
was they were using vitalik as sort of
like a lockup they were like look we
sent it's a one one uh coin that came
out the shiba inu coin which is like a
dog
another dog coin like dogecoin
they sent i think six five or six
billion dollars worth of their coin uh
to vitalik's wallet to essentially lock
it up they're like look that's all there
it can't be sold um and so yeah you're
not i can't be sold like it's there so
you don't have to worry about like you
know who owns this thing vitalik owns
this thing
and um it was partly marketing it was
partly their their way of like locking
away some of the supply
and what vitalik did was pretty awesome
india was going through a really tough
patch in covid so he got this thing and
what he did was he donated a billion
dollars of it immediately to india and
then he dumped the other five billion
and just burned it and just said uh you
know so so that like it would so that
the price if if he sold it all on the
open market it would um it would crash
the price so instead he took five
billion and just eliminated it from the
pool and gave a billion dollars to india
kept none of it for himself and helped a
lot of people in india out and he did
this like overnight as soon as he got it
and i just thought that that was like
you know a pretty remarkable thing from
a pretty you know remarkable guy who
he's that guy's amazing it's really cool
that guy and the sam bankman guy are
some probably the two most interesting
people i think in the world at the
moment
yeah the cool thing about that
for those who don't remember the sam
bank but freed guy he's currently the
wealthiest
person from crypto um
wealthiest known person from crypto so
you know nobody knows who satoshi is but
sam banker freed is the next one he's
got like 15 or 20 billion dollar net
worth from crypto including the exchange
he created
and um he if you talk if you listen to
interviews he's like not like any other
crypto zealot he just is like uh he's
like yeah i don't care about crypto like
i don't i don't i believe in it not
believe in people want this so i made a
product
and like that's his whole mindset and he
also is like obsessed with this idea of
like i forgot what it's called there's
some like a philanthropic thing he's
really into like uh
sam do you remember the name of this
it's like charitable ambition or some
like that it's like yeah he
basically
he was basically uh basically the idea
is like i'm just gonna get as wealthy as
possible and give it all away to
different stuff and it's okay for me to
be incredibly ambitious and do this
thing these things i don't really care
about because i'm just giving it away
anyway and he's giving away like during
his lifetime said last year's all right
breakout company you go for all right
breakout company i have um
i have open c so just to give you a
sense of open seas crazy growth
i had that too by the way started in
2017 and the
the bear market hit like pretty much
immediately
and i know people who were building like
their competitors and they ended up
folding because it was just like there
was no interest and these guys were like
you know the cockroaches that just
stayed alive
and
in 20 uh basically they in 2020 so last
year they did 24 million dollars in gmv
pretty small overall
um and they get uh 10 of that
uh they have i don't know what their
take rate is something like i think it's
even lower than that i think it's five
percent or something they it's in that
range so it was very small 24 million in
gross sales across the platform that's
not their sales that's what people
buying from each other so they just get
a small take this year 15 billion so
going from 24 million to 15 billion in
one year that's 650x
to me that's uh that's a breakout
company i know we've talked about them
before so it's not a big surprise but i
had to give it to him
so i had that as well but i came with
the backup because i actually thought
that you were gonna pick that so i had
open c as well i think it's amazing that
they basically just kind of created a
market and i think that's pretty badass
um or at least they were part of a
market that is was non-existent a couple
years ago all right so my second one is
someone who we talked about i'm gonna
botch his first name but his last name
is levels what's his first name peter
peter
p is it peter is it just peter okay i
think that's peter i thought it was a
weird let's call him pieter just about i
thought it was peter to be honest but
i'm gonna call him peter all right so
this guy is peter like theater that's
how we're gonna call that's what i
thought it was i thought there was an
eye in there in some weird area um all
right but we talked about this guy a
couple episodes ago but i've actually
been paying attention to him for like
three years and as far as i can tell
it's a one-person business and for the
longest time he would reveal all of his
revenue and for years it was like two or
three hundred thousand dollars a year in
revenue and he has a bunch of different
products he's got nomadlist.com
remoteok.com workers.co he even has a
cool website called rebase which is all
about going to uh portugal moving to
portugal so he's got like eight
different websites for the longest time
only like three four five hundred
thousand dollars a year in revenue like
neat but not that cool this year he got
close to five million in revenue and for
a one person internet business that's
pretty phenomenal and the remote thing
has basically
kind of caught up with him and he's
crushing it and this guy's an artist i
love him i think so he's kind of his own
entity and i think that he for me was
the breakout person of the year behind
opens yeah i think like that guy kind of
has my dream life which is funny that i
say that because i do own similar
businesses but i've always i've always
liked fetishized the idea of being a
one-person entrepreneur and being able
to do that level of revenue i just kind
of got ahead of myself and it's so
interesting i think i have a lot of
respect for him because i think he still
shares his numbers most of the guys that
get to this scale they almost always
stop sharing because everyone realizes
how much money they're making i have a
story of a guy who's going to come on
the pod soon
and he i've been talking to him and he
made um
10 million a year in profit in the early
2000s from uh a a lyric website
that was around for years so i have a
one person is it maloon maloon tesovic
no
but he is a similar similar story he's a
he's a russian jewish guy that guy a
russian jewish guy didn't didn't yeah i
also make like a dream i don't know he's
not a drinker eastern european oh my god
no okay that guy balloon didn't he do
something else that's really remarkable
now like he did the lyrics thing and
isn't he doing some other interesting
stuff
he works at expo right he's a partner at
expo gotcha uh all right andrew who do
you have uh sam has this like weird
indie breakout company that's not a
company it's just bro i chose open c
that's the most obvious one i chose that
i chose that one too so i had to get
used to so far i'm mr obvious sam's mr
suck up and uh let's see if andrew's got
something good here so
i wasn't trying to be better i was just
trying to be different
so so if there's one thing i really
really don't like it's middlemen
realtors uh investment bankers that kind
of stuff so i love this company
microacquire
for a long time if you wanted to buy a
tech business you were going to these
crappy listing websites with really like
really sketchy sites with really low
quality businesses uh and this guy
andrew basically came along and started
this company called microacquire and
it's for uh generally like profitable
sas businesses uh on the web and he's
just done a really really nice job of
doing it i'd say it's kind of like
zillow for buying a tech business um and
i i you know he kind of replaced flippa
and all these other kind of crappy
websites so i'm a big fan of what he's
doing and fighting just raised like 10
million bucks or something like that
we're all investors i think right
i am
i didn't invest but but uh i think it's
a good one well i invested a small a
very small amount like five thousand
dollars or one thousand dollars or
something like tiny but he uh he's
picking fights with people online too
he's kind of making himself to be a kind
of a villain to a certain group of
people which we'll see if that ends up
being uh a good idea who's he going
after
i forget the funny thing is i think he's
going after like uh he's basically
saying like he went after two groups so
he's like first like bootstrappers
need like some love like you know if
you're a profitable company like why is
that getting no attention and then the
second thing is he's going after
techcrunch because they don't cover
those types of companies they just they
basically work for the vcs it's kind of
like his angle it's like he's a good
angle he created a rival publication i
think called the bootstrappers to just
take a shot at techcrunch um i'm like i
will cover these companies if you guys
aren't going to
but then the only hypocrisy is that he's
raising a bunch of venture capital so i
think you know that part you know breaks
down a little bit uh but i think he's
doing a good job of picking a fight and
there's this general's twitter strategy
which is if you like
totally sell out to your mission which
is like
both a good and a bad thing you could
just like there's a guy who um
uh i i was friendly with chris heard
he created a company that's around
remote work and they help basically like
manage companies like laptops and desks
your desk setup when you work from home
they'll help you as a company manage
your workers desk setups
and uh so he just every tweet is just
about how remote work is taking over and
how everything else is gonna die and
it'll just be he's just that's the
propaganda machine and you just keep
beating that drum every day every day he
just keeps talking about how the office
is dead remote work is going up but he
cannot be wrong and yeah and it's just
like you know
a total like brainwashing of content but
you know it's it's pretty effective when
people do do that i can't really bring
myself to do that exactly but it works
okay so who um
i would give it to open c oh i'm getting
it okay great i love it
right yeah great microacquire is cool
but open c is just there's levels and
micro
honestly i would do yours man i think um
yours is the most unique right i think
open c had a big win but it's like you
know i think venture-backed
kind of like of the moment crypto stuff
mine i think everyone knows about but i
think what peter's doing is very unique
um and it's just when you think about
lifestyle i think he has the best
possible lifestyle of any of the people
here what's a story where a guy goes to
a party hosted by whoever like you know
some rockefeller type it's like you know
his friend is saying this guy's the
richest man in the world he's got
everything he's got this he's got that
he's got cars he's got servants he's got
everything and then the guy who's the
guest goes uh yeah but i have something
he'll never have
enough enough and um yeah that's the
kurt vonnegut yeah it was kurt vonnegut
and joseph heller i think right
so that's the version of you know andrew
you had peter levels but you you didn't
have enough and so you kept going
and there's a part of you that envies
that lifestyle still uh all right we're
giving it to you and once you start once
you start once you get in office once
you have employees you have this beast
to feed whereas peter could just check
out
right
one of these days we should do a story
of someone who has done that who went
one way and they just said ah it
we're gonna go the opposite
and went back i love those arms all
right i get this one
uh all right so uh the unsexy simple
business that you saw this year i'll go
first we talked about it this guy named
quinn i think his name is quinn emmett
is that the guy saying spider right
is it snyder i don't remember what it
was actually but he had a vent he had a
vending machine business and he started
he was just working in sales at like
some tech company and i i did like a
little checkup on him he's doing like
thirty thousand dollars a month in
revenue and half of that is profit and
he basically started with fifteen
hundred dollars he's got uh some vending
machines throughout uh his city i forget
where he is california i think started
with fifteen hundred dollars now he has
software that tells him when the things
need to get refilled and he says he only
works 10 hours a week on it i think
that's pretty cool i think that's pretty
awesome
i love that by the way quinn snyder is a
basketball coach
so definitely he's definitely not
quinstein or something else
i think it was emmett quinn uh andrew
who you got for best unsexy or simple
business that you saw this year i feel
like you see a ton of these so this is
probably the easiest category for you
i see a lot and i looked i looked at a
bunch of ones that people had brought us
and i just i can't really share but this
is one i came across recently that i
think is genius so some guy um he went
and he basically built a fake interior
of a private jet in los angeles like
they used like a movie set or whatever
and then they just rent it out to
influencers so that they can take photos
where it looks like they're on a private
jet but they're not and they charge 70
bucks an hour i think it's booked out
like 12 hours a day probably doing like
20 to 40k a month and i can't imagine
the margins would be less than 80
and i was like that's amazing
you could just build this thing hire a
bunch of people in the movie business to
build it over a weekend and then you
know you can own that for like years
what was it called
uh it's la private jet studio it's on
pure space which is like a um
a photo photo uh shoot like a studio
listing
that is so that's a great one um all
right i have one i'm gonna steal this
from our friend of the pod cody sanchez
uh sam you sent this link earlier and i
think this is a great one did you st
take the one that i sent you because she
has a bunch of that's the one that's
what i'm taking it was better than the
one i had so i was like oh this is we'll
use this one instead so she by the way
her tick tock is blown up so she's
always on my i know she's crazy dude her
last one just got 10 million views
that's insane like her she has half a
million followers on tick tock i always
see them
when i'm because i use tik tok a bunch
and i'm always like oh like i was in my
head i would just see like i don't know
30 comments i'd be like oh you know
tick tock's so hard and like when i saw
that it actually has added up it's just
you know yet another reminder of the
value of just keep going compound the
the wins over time so she was doing this
thing she goes here's a boring business
that um that that you love
and um it's called american striping
and all it is is this woman owns this
business and it just paints
the white line that you need for like a
road like lane basically or like a
parking spot you know it's like i need
to paint these white straight lines and
so she has this company american
striping i think it started about three
years ago
and uh you know four hundred thousand
dollars the first year seven million the
second year 15 million almost the third
year and just crushing it just
absolutely crushing it and according to
cody seventy percent profit yes exactly
somewhere 60 70 profit margins
i don't i don't know i don't know much
about it because again my research was
watching this tick tock five minutes
before this pod but uh
what a beautiful business and what a you
know what a great reminder that like
you know you you read about elon musk
and you're like oh i have to like send
rockets to mars and then you read about
the girl who's like i drop straight
white lines and i can make millions of
dollars a year and it just reminds you
you know you can win the game any any
way so she's my pick i love that i am i
would vote for that one okay i'm gonna
take that in honor of cody so we are at
one one one right now so we're one each
by the way i have a a little honorable
mention here an unsexy business that's
done extremely well have you guys looked
at crocs stock
yeah crushing it thanks to post malone
dude 2020 when the pandemic happened so
march 2020 you could you could have
bought a pair of crocs for i don't know
how much crocs go for let's call it a
hundred bucks maybe there's a little
less uh you could buy a pair of crocs
and you could buy the stock for ten
dollars a share it's now up 13 x in one
year just during the the pandemic was
good to crocs and uh i just thought that
was like an amazing winner uh out of
this like pandemic time is it possible
is that who's driving it
he was he kind of hopped on that trend
really early and then they created this
new thing called like crocs i forget
what they're called but they're like
charms that you put on your crocs and if
you drive around the midwest or in the
south like how do we make every glare
what could we do oh let's dangle charms
off of them
do you know what i'm talking about like
my wife is obsessed with these and she
buys them for our kids and puts them on
yeah it's like like a you get like a
soccer ball like pin or like a football
pin or like some cartoon and the kids
are obsessed with it and they're
crushing it right now post malone uh
started making them popular and a lot of
country um
music people like luke uh combs so you
probably have no idea who that is
started wearing camouflage crocs gotcha
yeah who knew uh who knew
by the way sam i got another real quick
pop quiz for you
hands up so i see you're not you're not
looking it up
i want you to guess the monthly visitors
to onlyfans.com
20 million a month okay you're close
it's 250 million tell you're off by 10x
an order of magnets is it really that
was gonna be my other unsexy business
was actually the business of sexy uh
which was like i had no idea they they
get 250 million visitors per month
that's insane that'd be one of the top
websites in the world then there's
another one called chatterbait that's it
you know a broke man's version of only
fans i gets 300 million oh my god it's
insane um
so you know but it didn't crazy didn't
only fans did they say that they're no
longer allowing nudity they did for a
second and then they reversed course
stupid
like no more porn yeah facebook's like
no more photos you know it doesn't work
that's so stupid um
by the way average visit duration four
minutes
all right we'll go to the next category
your best investment okay so what was
your best investment of 2021 uh let's
kick it off with andrew
so um i would uh the boring answer is
aeropress i think but i've already
talked about that on the pod um we we
bought that maybe four or five months
ago and that's been awesome so far but
that story hasn't played out yet so the
one and we haven't really done that much
in the last year so the best one
thing that i've been buying myself
is actually a company called pershing
square holdings i don't think i've
talked about it
so i have about 95 of my net worth in
tiny and our kind of core businesses um
but i've been quietly building kind of a
backup forever rich retirement portfolio
of stocks real estate brick and mortar
businesses we own a chain of restaurants
we have a hotel wait what a bunch of
conventional stuff
uh i just known a bunch of restaurants
in victoria i know what is that we own a
hotel in st louis
oh marshall
yeah yeah with marshall exactly is the
hotel business cool
it's amazing basically we bought this uh
that we bought like a apartment building
and converted it into all airbnb and we
took it from we bought it super cheap
and now it's yielding and you're a
billionaire maybe you're my billy of the
year
uh i don't think not yet
working on it it sounds like uh
something you had to think about it that
means you you might be round upping to
it
no i i no i i don't think i am um i
don't really i i don't really have like
a good picture on that stuff that's a
good answer though i know businesses if
the answer is i don't think i am then
the answer then that's a good sign yeah
what's that people say i don't i don't i
don't spend a lot of i don't spend a lot
of time on that stuff because
you know a lot of people who are
billionaires on paper like you know
it doesn't really matter right you could
invest in some startup it could get
valued at 20 billion dollars you can own
one percent whatever like i i just don't
i don't spend too much time on that so
anyway i i've been thinking about this
and i go if everything goes pear-shaped
i want to still be rich and i want to
have enough money to live a great life
and so and that's by that guy you like
right bill ackman
yeah yeah so i've been following bill
for five or six years and i found that
he had this holding company called
pershing square holdings and what he did
is really smart so he he had a hedge
fund and when you have a hedge fund you
have a whole bunch of investors and they
give you cash to invest but at any given
time they can freak out and they can
take their money back so you could be in
a down you know down you could own an
amazing business and you could be forced
to sell at the wrong time because an
investor redeems and so he created this
holding company in amsterdam i think he
raised four billion dollars um and he
called it pershing square holdings and
it's basically a public holding company
that just owns a bunch of stocks and it
owns really great stuff it owns chipotle
domino's hilton
lowe's restaurant brands international
so like burger king popeyes that kind of
stuff and universal music and so it's
this really diversified blue chip stock
portfolio and as i dug into it i
realized that it perpetually trades at a
discount to the net assets there so if
there's a hundred dollars worth of
stocks it trades at about 70 meaning
that the market could go down 30 percent
before you've lost any money in the in
the portfolio and then on top of that
you have bill ackman managing your money
and he does crazy like he last year
he turned 25 million dollars into 2.7
billion
and i got to ride along with him on that
so anyway i've been buying that
almost exclusively i've got probably
like 60 percent of my portfolio in this
and i just keep buying more and more
every month uh and i've quadrupled my
money i think over the last couple of
years did he do this awesome that that
crazy trade that he made last year the
covert trade was that out of these
vehicles or that was out of a separate
vehicle
yeah that was in this vehicle
and anyone could have bought that
and he did the universal
actually last year or something like
that
yeah you've talked about this you like
um okay great so that's a good one uh
sam what you got your best investment um
i bought a i bought a a big lot in
austin kind of boring but i bought a big
lot in austin i used um
an asset-backed loan so i used cash to
buy it like i told them i bought it in
cash in reality it was a loan at a one
percent interest rate and i
it's not the story again hasn't played
out but it's already appreciated because
i've gotten offers on it but i'll make
about five hundred thousand dollars in
tax free profit with very little work
and the work that i've been doing on it
is fun i'm learning a skill i'm learning
how to develop a home profitably
um
so uh that that's gonna be my it's
probably not my best just like investing
in the s p 500 that's up 30
that i mean that's but that's not much
of an investment i didn't do anything
and so the uh my my austin real estate
project will be the most like actively i
think active thing that i'm managing and
make the most
that's a good one uh by the way the
youtube video on your personal youtube
channel the uh this is sampar or the
sampara yeah just my name you you show
the the lot the kind of like the rundown
shack that's there today it's great uh
it's fun right
it's way more in watch that and what you
just said will be way more entertaining
it's great
but i also i feel like you might make
500 grand but if you'd made 5 million
passively it wouldn't feel as good as
exactly that's why i'm saying you've
done it it's better because it's fun
like it's i'm basically developing a
skill uh and it's been quite fun and the
tax implications are quite nice yeah
that's great um okay good my my best
investment i'm gonna go with this
startup that i invested in so last year
i think it was last year last year i
created a rolling fund and it was
basically said hey if anybody wants to
invest in startups alongside me you know
you don't have to have the network you
don't have to have the knowledge
all you got to have is the cash you
could do this and i was like okay
i wanted to start it i was like i want
to start this off i want to make it
enticing for somebody to join because
you could invest in
a number of people who are professional
full-time investors who have been doing
this for a decade so i was kind of
thinking like why would somebody invest
in me and so i said let me juice it up a
little bit let me put three of my
personal angel investments into this
deal uh into this like fund and uh so
they'll be able to say look i i get to
sort of like great i get grandfathered
into these deals that you've already
done
that's a very
kind of you and
i was self-serving like i wanted my fund
to get subscribers quickly so i was like
how do i provide more value here here's
here's some free value now looking back
it actually has turned out to be very
kind because the very first deal that i
put in is a company called deal d-e-e-l
and what deal does is it's the easiest
way to hire a contractor um so like i
was paying i wanted to hire this guy in
australia the guy who actually first was
editing our podcast like how do i pay
this podcast editor in australia and so
i was like oh um you know do i need to
go get a lawyer to make a contract and
how do i pay them in his local currency
and then what are the compliance rules
around that how much taxes do i need to
pay like i don't i don't understand all
this so i went to deal and literally in
five minutes i was like
uh here's the guy's name here's his
email address here's where he lives it's
like here's a contract it's like would
you like to add a confidentiality clause
yeah yeah toss that in it's like guac on
my burrito like you know
i'll go for that and then it was like
great it's sent for signature and the
payments will come out of your bank
account and it'll pay him in australian
dollars automatically every month and i
was like wow that was like kind of
magical it basically replaced you know
what a bunch of humans would have to do
so i loved it so i ended up chasing down
the founder and i was like yo your
product is amazing um how do i invest in
this and he was like oh you know i'd
love to have you
and i didn't invest right then and then
you know when i followed up he was like
oh dude we just closed a thing sorry i
forgot like you know you didn't follow
up so so i missed the first round
and then i almost missed the second one
what was the valuation of the first one
first one might have been i don't
remember exactly but it's like a startup
you know like maybe 12 million cap or 20
million cap something like that
and so uh he's like don't worry i'll get
you into the next round i was like okay
great so he messages me one day he says
brother like you know i got your spot
for you next round's coming together let
me know i'm like oh i'm in 25k no
questions asked he's like great got you
in
and i was like i was like actually you
know one question i guess what is the
valuation actually what does it happen
to be
and he's like you know i don't know if i
can say this probably i can say this it
was like
a million and i was like what
and i was like uh and i was like okay
and i didn't want to go back on my words
i i like the product i like the founder
a lot and i was like i said i'm in so
i'm in and i was like ah okay
whatever and then i was like you know do
you have like crazy traction like how
are you getting this this thing he's
like
you know we're doing well but like you
know he told me the number and i was
like that's an absurd valuation for this
thing i was like who's doing this deal
and his andreessen was doing the deal
he's like these guys are nuts uh well i
don't know why they're doing this but
whatever i wrote the check did it
anyways
it that it was valued this year at five
and a half billion
um like you know two years later they
said he and the founder tweeted this out
so i can share this they ramped up
revenue from four million to 50 million
in arr in one year
and um they went from 50 employees to
550 employees in one year
and so this is just like an insane
amount of traction that's like you know
actually andreessen knew what they were
doing they you know they they bet on
this before because i think the revenue
was definitely less than four million at
the time it was re it was valued at 200
million and so you know the value
investor and andrew would have been
dying in that moment it just didn't make
any sense it didn't make sense to me
even but this has turned out to be a
pretty amazing deal uh you know so if
not including dilution which is a big
factor here so take that for what it's
worth so 12 million into five and a half
billion is 458 so your 25 000 in that 12
round would have been worth over 11
million
yes exactly and my buddy my buddy ryan
uh did that deal at that at that round
and uh reminded me as such about like
the crazy markup and so you know the 25k
has turned into half a million but man
that's the difference between half a
million and 12 million was following up
oh my god
all right
so wait is this my best investment or
worst investor maybe this is my worst
investment actually i mean 25k to half a
million by the way well it would have
been good and then i put it in the the
rolling fund so now you know most of the
economics went to my investors dude
that's crazy that that that mistake
that's a 10 million dollar mistake
yeah and it was by the way this was a
period of like i don't know less than a
year between the between like when when
one round happened and the next round
happened so you know could have uh
could yeah coulda woulda shoulda all
right so who are we giving this round to
best investment
me okay for my sob story at least i have
at least i have this to lean back on
all right let's go to worst investment
what was your worst investment of 2021
i'll go first mine's easy
zillow
i bought silver on that one yeah i i
only bought
three stocks individual stocks this year
one was playboy and playboy kind of
makes sense because only a billion
dollar valuation 200 million in revenue
and i thought the brand was easily worth
that i'm actually thinking about buying
aston martin stock at aston martin is
only valued at like one or two billion
dollars it's like the cheapest car maker
but i think they're gonna have a
resurgence so i'm thinking about doing
that but i bought playboy thinking that
was my logic and i was wrong but then
zillow was way wrong zillow was wrong
because i bought at it's the most
expensive point tell people why we
bought this stock we bought it because
we're in this chat group and our friend
nikita and austin reef were like
zillow's the greatest thing ever and so
i bought like 25 or 50 grand worth of
zillow and i agreed with them i thought
yeah you know you're right like whenever
i go to a fancy neighborhood i just pull
up zillow and i like browse it all the
time it's kind of a category definer
like defining company like i'm on board
with zillow i thought how much were they
worth when we bought like 15 or 20. i
don't know it's down 56 percent so i
bought 100k and now my 100k is 44k uh
left it made sense like i don't regret
it
like i'm on board with it but the
problem was is that it went down just
because like we were wrong then it went
down because they it up with
buying all those houses and it went down
even more yeah so we were wrong like
twice and by the way they they lost 56
of their value in a year where the
housing market went like bananas so you
know it's not like
there was something out of their control
and their industry that was doing poorly
you know didn't
didn't rich barton come back or
something was he the guy he's the
original founder and a really great
investor and a great leader great
entrepreneur yeah and and he came back
and he tried to do the house buying
stuff i would still i would honestly
maybe
i think it's a great company it's
awesome i think basically what happened
was a bunch of bad stuff happened
including one tick tock went really
viral explaining how like they're evil
because they're like big corporations
buying hundreds of homes and that
totally them if anyone's
tick tock is the winner here the fact
that they haven't disintermediated real
realtors though like the fact you can't
or maybe you can and i'm just not aware
but i just want to be able to list my
house on zillow and then have an open
outcry auction one day like where you
say like on this day i want to have an
auction everyone's going to bid and then
we'll get the maximum price and they do
all the paperwork like that would be i
invested in money i invested in a
company that does that they were called
rumor it's kind of a silly name but they
re-change it to also a silly name it's
called dorsey so
yeah it's i gotta call this is not bad i
like darcy so don't
doors it's like the word door and then
s-e-y
and uh it's a live home auction and uh
it's started by the guy who started
hello alfred
kind of a cool company i just sent it to
you in the chat
yeah so zillow was your worst investment
hey just before we jump i want to know
about playboy so what's the what's the
thesis there like they still have the
magazine obviously it's kind of a you
know there's a lot of legacy
because it can't be the magazine like
where's the money coming from yeah
merchandise basically and so they own
the they they own the playboy mansion
which is worth uh nine figures i believe
and they recently did a spec in 2020 and
so they reported 200 million dollars in
revenue in 2021 or that's what the
forecast is going to be when i invested
i think their market cap was just a hair
above 1 billion
and um basically my my logic right now
it's one exactly 1 billion my logic was
basically like i'm pretty sure that
brand is worth more than that like if
they just like put their logo on stuff i
was like i know young people don't
really care about it as much but i think
that brand is pretty valuable and i
couldn't put a value on it but i thought
it was above what they were trading for
so it was kind of i kind of just made a
kind of a gut call but it's down
half wasn't it it was a guy the guy who
bought that was the guy who bought
twinkies or hostess or something random
like yeah
yeah like um yeah
he was the guy who bought twinkies made
a ton of money on it then he bought pbr
i think it is a i mean it's a very
iconic it's a really iconic brand yeah i
know that like they tried i had a friend
that tried that almost bought uh this
guy the guys at the chive almost sold to
playboy and they told me about going to
the mansion and they told me that they
playboy was thinking about selling the
mansion and they told me like how much
it was worth and it was it's like a
crazy high number and i thought well
just with this stuff like this is
worth more than the if you're only fans
why would you not just buy playboy i
think it's really interesting you don't
need it
that brand i mean what's it worth that
you know i don't know 500 million people
know your name and associate it like
that's got to be worth
to to a company that has a money plan
if you are a money printer what what
does it take to accelerate your brand
like that that i don't know that's well
let's be let's be real i mean tai lopez
is gonna
turn into some sort of cryptocurrency
all right where are you what's yours
andrew yeah so mine i can't say what it
is we didn't actually announce the
business but
so
the mistake we made is we bought an
ember what i mean by that is it's like
this little tiny ember and it could turn
into a bonfire if you blow on it a lot
but you have to be very attentive and
we're not set up to be attentive we're
kind of management by neglect we buy
these businesses we plug in ceos and
then they go on to do great and the
problem is when you have this little
tiny
startup this is a business it was a real
business with real revenue and profits
but it was very small and we liked what
we saw but the problem is we couldn't
attract someone great to run it and so
the business the ember just kind of
burnt out over time and we ended up
spending like a million bucks so it was
just a total money bonfire uh and
pointless and unsatisfying and so the
lesson for us is
just board a cruise ship you know don't
don't try and build your own boat that's
a good announcement two good analogies
ember and cruise ship um all right my
worst investment
uh
i'm gonna give you the fast answer
because i think we're gonna run short on
time all right mine is holding
coveted winners for too long so i had
this amazing run-up on zoom stock fastly
which is a like uh edge you know like a
cloud or what's called a cdn um and
agora which does like you know voice and
video um sdks so they power clubhouse
and things like that
and i own these stocks they ran up like
crazy you know 2x 3x or whatever in like
a very short amount of time
and then they've all come crashing back
down to earth um
you know in the last six months or so
and so i lost money just by holding on
to the coveted winners for for too long
even when like for example with agora
i got in because i knew clubhouse was
growing but then i was the one who
kind of almost like famously called the
clubhouse is gonna fail and it's gonna
gonna tank
and yet i still held my agora i forgot
to sell my agora stock and it's cut in
half um you know so that that sort of
thing so i would say my i lost a nice
chunk of change holding my covered
winners for too long how awesome would
it be if you could short private
companies like imagine if you saw
clubhouse and you could go and short it
and maybe maybe there is a way to do it
if anyone has any ideas i'd love to hear
them but um
stuff like that is quite obvious
uh that if you have you ever used poly
market
it's basically like a crypto betting
it's like a like a bookie basically but
you could bet on anything you could bet
on sports games you could bet will joe
biden get coveted uh you could bet
whatever and it's only a yes or no so
there's so and the market sets the line
so basically if everybody thinks yes
then proportionately
no will be rewarded like if you bet no
but two-thirds of people bet yes you're
going to get a payout more than
one-to-one on your money because you're
taking the underdog side of things and
um and so there's a so this idea of
prediction markets works really well in
in crypto and uh and so there's a few of
these that are out there
um i love betting on poly market dude we
should do we should do an annual uh
betting episode where we all make
predictions and bets and then we put it
on poly market and we have to put our
own money up that'd be awesome do you
still stand by that is club what's the
update on clubhouse
are you going to be right
yeah it looks like it like the charts
all you know it's a it looks like mount
everest right it's like goes up and then
it goes straight there's there's not a
world where like it's just like maybe
not growing a ton but they still have
like a million people a day using it or
something like that
uh well look you never count out an
entrepreneur those guys are really
talented entrepreneurs they can always
pivot uh it's that you know the product
as it is today did not
become what people bet on it to become
right andreessen put it a four billion
dollar price tag on it basically betting
that it's gonna become like a twitter
it's gonna become a facebook or a snap
and uh it's not happening uh that has
that hasn't happened the one good thing
is that they they have the same kind of
like hype cycle or not hype i shouldn't
say that but like
uh trend fad cycle
in different countries so like in india
they'll get like it happened in america
they got super popular and then usage
faded it wasn't super sticky
and then the same thing will happen in
india it'll get super popular and then
it'll start to fade in popularity and so
the overall numbers aren't like totally
zero but it's
the problem is if you're a leaky bucket
you're a leaky bucket it's just a matter
of time tall the water's gone and uh
that's i don't know i think i think i'm
right but i don't honestly don't pay too
much attention to it but people will
often tweet at me charts of their
downloads going down to be like you're
right so that's all i know it's
basically people cherry-picking evidence
andrew andrew chen's got to come on the
pod you know that right
oh is he yeah will he be able to talk to
me or am i blocked from the pod too
we'll see he'll he'll block you he'll
meet you all right uh who's the winner
on that one
um i'm gonna go i like i think andrew
had a good lesson in there all right
we'll go with that
oh that's we're gonna go andrew there
all right let me um i'm gonna uh i'm
gonna combine the next one can i do that
yeah okay so i'm gonna combine it with
favorite digital tool
favorite physical tool
and best product under
100 and above a thousand and i'll go
first so favorite digital is true bill
andrew you should use true bill you said
that you forget subscriptions true bill
is awesome like just today i didn't
realize that me and my wife both had an
amazon prime membership true bill i paid
like 50 bucks oh no or 10 it's like
really cheap and it's a sick app that
syncs your bank account and tells you
the subscriptions that you have and it
makes it easy to cancel it have you
heard of that
sweet they just got acquired
i don't i don't know if it works in
canada but you just gotta acquire for
1.3 billion by rocket mortgages your guy
dan gilbert
um so pretty awesome favorite physical
tool is this is kind of physical is a 50
app called camo that's let you use your
iphone for
uh like high def uh video calls pretty
amazing and then favorite product that
was above
uh that was under 100 was lock a box
it's a 38
box that i keep in my pantry that my
wife knows the code of and she puts
things that i don't want to have that i
don't have self-control so she'll put
like uh sweets in there and sometimes if
i want to lock my phone for the weekend
she'll put it in there so that's awesome
and then above a thousand i bought a
fancy car a mercedes
amg station wagon that i love
dude that was great okay uh andrew so
we're doing a digital product physical
product or kind of like a
cheap or expensive thing you liked
okay so um digital product uh
consumerlab.com so it's like 49 bucks a
year and it's basically wire cutter but
for food and supplements so everything
from like vitamin d to seaweed snacks to
baby food they buy every single brand
they test it and it's pretty shocking
like i just today learned that the
seaweed snacks that i've been giving my
kids you know have like a bunch of
arsenic in them right so it's just crazy
stuff that could affect your life
my favorite physical tool is this
amazing thing my wife gifted for me
randomly that i never thought i would
use it's basically this game called the
loser game and you play with friends and
you basically all draw a card and on
each card is a really kind of up
deep question so
for example
how have you blamed someone for an issue
that was if you're truly honest largely
your fault or name a surprising basic
embarrassing gap in your knowledge or
anyway you go around in a circle you
answer this i did this on a retreat with
a couple friends that i did and these
were all guys i know really really well
and i left going holy there's just
so many cool stories and interesting
facts that we don't know about one
another and this game kind of
elicits it so that's been awesome
and then physical thing that i bought
this year i bought a house up at the
lake about 40 minutes out of town here
and it's been the best thing i could
ever do just great place to go and hang
out with family and check out of work
and even though it's close it feels like
a whole other world away that's great
and i've seen the house it's awesome but
i got a quick story on that thing you
just said uh my first business i started
with my two best friends from college
and uh this is the sushi business or
whatever we we met the chef and the chef
goes all right here he goes he goes you
guys are you guys man i love your guys's
kind of like vibe like you guys are i
can tell you guys really like each other
he goes how long you guys know each
other like did you just meet or
while we're like no we've
and we were just saying now we're thick
as thieves we've known each other for
years
and he goes you can see you guys know
each other pretty well huh and we're
like yeah like why why he goes he goes
uh sean what's uh what's the hardest
thing trevor's ever been through
i was like uh
i have no idea he's like you know like
just name something maybe and i was like
i honestly have no clue and we did and
all three of us had no idea of just
what's the hardest thing that your your
best friend has been through and um
[Music]
and he's like oh he goes he goes he goes
yeah i kind of noticed this he goes
y'all talk but you don't have
conversations oh and i was like oh
do mike drop and he goes he goes so you
know you don't need to do this now but
he's like but try it like go go a little
deeper um just ask yourself these
questions and we did it that night we
kind of asked each other that question
and then by the end we're all like dude
i didn't know that about you like i feel
like i knew you way better you know like
i really i really know you now um and so
that was a great reminder of like
sometimes these questions can can take
you you know further with your friends
totally it's a superpower one of the
questions i ask people when i have lunch
i'll have like a small talk you know
first time lunch with someone and i'll
just randomly try and ask them are you
happy or are you happy with where your
life is right now and it's weird they
will just go down a rabbit trail and
tell you all sorts of crazy stuff you
wouldn't normally tell somebody are you
just mind people throughout
victoria
all right so i'll
it well it just builds builds connection
right i'll do mine okay so favorite
digital thing uh this app called
othership uh it's a breathwork app i do
it every morning i love it it wakes me
up it makes me feel good it's it slows
me down and it speeds me up at the same
time it slows me down from just rushing
into my day feeling behind
and then it speeds me up because when i
come out of it i'm like i feel
just like electric i feel like i'm on
fire i could do whatever i want now
so other ship is the name of that app i
love that app um
favorite uh what is it favorite
okay my favorite physical tool is um
this is gonna sound stupid all right so
i grew out my hair
and um you know
i grow my hair just to like do it just
to kind of have a like i don't know just
have a change to do something different
but i don't know anything about how to
take care of hair and i'm like a really
messy disorganized person who doesn't
like you know i don't look in the mirror
until 7pm that night i'm like oh i
didn't haven't even looked at myself
today and that doesn't really work when
you got long hair like high maintenance
hair so i went to a stylist and i was
like you know can i get a little trim
and uh she was like what do you want i
was like i have no idea i have no idea
what i want and also
uh what i really want is like can you
just like cut the haircut like half an
hour short and just tell me what i
should be doing like with my hair and
she's like what do you mean i was like i
was like so like i get in the shower if
i want to do shampoo like here's how i
do it you tell me if that's correct and
i went through like these ultra basics
with her
and she was like what do you mean and
then she was laughing but then through
that conversation she's like oh like no
no when you shampooed like don't be
doing it on the roots because you're
gonna end up stripping away all your
natural oils like just do your
conditioner and shampoo like from the
middle to the end and like oh you're
sleep you know your hair is really
frizzy and you probably don't know why
but like do you sleep on a cotton
pillowcase and i was like yeah of course
and she's like you need to switch that
for silk because imagine you're spending
eight hours a night rubbing your hair
into this thing so she gave me these
like three little things like a silk
pillowcase this like uh curling cream
she's like just use this because your
hair won't look like it's just black or
white white
dude we have silk things in our in our
house all over well yeah because if you
have a black girl thing yeah no it is
there's like this whole thing the curly
girl method and like that so
anyways
i learned so much about hair in like
half an hour it was amazing and i felt
so relieved i was like ah this is like
this class of life school i just missed
and like i'm too embarrassed or too like
kind of
busy to like think about it but like
taking the time thinking about it was
awesome and so you know the little silk
pillow and a couple other things were
great little wins for me when when you
go to restaurants what i do all the time
is i just say they'll say what do you
want and i'll say i just want meat and
vegetables give me whatever's popular or
whatever's best do you ever do that no
but well i'll often ask what's best or
i'll say the best question is uh you
know what uh like what do you eat after
work like what's the best thing that you
like to eat dude it makes him so
uncomfortable though i ask that all the
whenever i order i almost always do that
it makes them very uncomfortable and
they freak out just like you did like
when i get a haircut i'm like what do
you want i'm like just make me look sexy
you know just like make me look hot just
like yeah whatever chef's choice is a
hella underrated way to live life so is
but it makes them so uncomfortable
not you might be putting them on putting
too much pressure on them i tell them i
say look this is where i am it can't get
worse than this don't worry i trust you
and i tell every haircut i said don't
worry what you do my hair grows fast i
take a lot of pressure off them same
thing with the food you know tell me
what you eat after work uh by the way
i'm not picky and i'm already in a good
mood so i'm gonna love whatever you give
me and then you know take the product
that's that's a good one i'm gonna say
that all right and then your last uh
you're you're over 100 and under 100.
the uh what's let's see over a hundred
uh oh i hired a chef so i don't know why
more people don't do this like
dude that's such a conceited thing to
say
no no yeah cancel me and be like yeah
because i can't afford it no what i mean
is if you can buy a nice car
or you know like i would never buy a
nice car before a chef like my order of
operations you drive a bmw
[Music]
no no no i don't even think that's the
right comparison i think it's
a lot of people who are middle class or
upper middle class have a cleaner
a chef is just slightly more expensive
than that it's not crazy expensive
that's pretty expensive to have somebody
who who preps meals and i don't do it
every day so you know you could do three
days a week or you can do you know
whatever um it is the biggest life
quality change because you get your time
back plus you eat healthier plus it's
actually tasty because you probably
aren't a great cook
or i'm not at least
plus like you know they prep little
things for like my dog or my baby who's
like a picky eater and like
it just saves so much time energy and
mental like kind of like uh mind space i
guess to do this so for me i'm like i
would cut 10 other things before this so
like if you got some money right you
can't do this you got no money but you
got some money you got some money to
play with like don't angel invest hire a
chef you know don't don't buy like a go
buy like a used kind of like middle road
car don't buy like a nice car if you're
buying a tesla get a chef that's why
that's my like you know
if you're in that game those are the
kind of trade-offs you can make
and above uh below a thousand
uh oh jambis i think i've talked about
this before oh my god i love these
things
you don't like it you don't like jammies
like they're just boxers with pockets
very soft boxers with pockets and no
hole
uh
do you wear them do you wear them though
day-to-day or only when you're at home
well i'm at home every day what do you
mean
well let's bring it out you know if
there's no if there's no hole and you
put them on under jeans
i don't know
just a shitty version of this
replacement for short so i like to just
walk around my boxers all day that's
like when i'm most comfortable so this
is the socially acceptable more
comfortable they're like a little longer
so you're not showing too much thai
there's no hole they got pockets so you
can carry your phone around so it's like
the best way to just wear your boxers at
home
like you're saying like your
mother-in-law your mother-in-law
mother-in-law's
going to wear boxers around the house
because if you just wear shorts they're
just as comfortable and you'd look like
sean's effects he's been talking about
these things for like three years now
i i've worn them they're very very
comfortable i have a pair i like them
but i wouldn't wear them like if they're
people in my house i wouldn't wear lemon
shorts instead that have like the
underwear in the uh as the light they're
still comfortable we're not all
trillionaires so we can't all get
lululemon we can get jammies right
all right can i can i batch the next one
again yeah all right so check this out
so um we're giving that round to sam all
right i'll take that uh thank you a
thing you learned about yourself this
year and best relationship hack i'll go
first because mine are going to be
really fast best relationship hack this
year i do weekly meetings with my wife
using this best self journal and it's
just like a prompt it's an hour-long
prompt of questions and you get to know
each other better exactly what you've
talked about with your buddy it's been
awesome that's the best hack i've had
and the one thing i learned this year
i'll say two things one i don't ask you
a question about the relationship one
yeah are you both equally into it or is
one of you like more into doing it than
the other we're both equally into it
okay i think that and so like i've
always been a fan of therapy like i've
gone to therapy like regardless if i'm
healthy or unhealthy it's just like
going to the gym and so i was like we
should do couples counseling even though
everything's great and but i didn't
really judge we didn't jive with anyone
and so i thought this one is actually
better it works yeah and it's like 25
for one time and then
so sean i mean i totally relate to what
you said though like i'm projecting he's
not into it and i tried to do this with
my wife do like uh you almost want to do
like a weekly board meeting like hey
let's talk about our relationship my way
well
it's not run like a business meeting
exactly but like it just has like like
like you know like the five languages of
love like that's like one that's like
one conversation that's like you'll have
that one week and then the next
conversation will be uh uh tell me about
your childhood
right i think i think someone needs to
build like an operating system kind of
like how you would have board meetings
and all this stuff for marriage
eos right like what does our family
stand for yeah exactly exactly that was
a great idea yeah and then one thing i
learned about myself which is i actually
don't like owning as fancy stuff it kind
of stresses me out so i like bought a
fancy watch and i was like oh my god
this is horrible it's freaking me out
and but what i learned this year is i
had a number of net worth in my head and
i was like if i hit this number i'm
never going to worry again and i'm not
going to chase money i hit that number i
still worry and i still chase it's never
enough
yeah and now now it's always 2x you know
and there's a the new yorker didn't did
a study where they like asked a bunch of
wealthy people and like it doesn't
matter if the person had uh 1 million
100 000 or 50 million they always said
they'd be more comfortable if they had
2x
yeah all right you want to go sean
uh yeah okay so best relationship hack
uh
i literally just wrote this as soon as i
read it i go shut the up
uh
i learned this year how to really just
shut the up in a relationship
meaning like not everything needs to be
talked about not everything needs to be
said
not every like you know pot needs to be
stirred not every issue needs to be
discussed not every like
worry needs to be a thing like
just shut up and uh like just shut up
and enjoy it just shut up and listen
more
um and just shut up and like don't
complain don't don't talk about like
constantly improving and changing it
like just shut up a little bit and so
that was my relationship backwards
there's many times where
you've got you probably know this
because you know me pretty well sam i'm
kind of a pot stir
um and i like to like
i don't feel alive till somebody's like
you know laughing or angry or whatever
in a conversation i'm like yeah now
we're doing it that's true it's not how
everybody is but your intentions are
mostly always good which most
your mo your intentions are mostly
always good if it's if you just want to
call it's just because you feel
like laughing yeah i'm trying to amuse
myself the difference is
are your were your parents debaters and
that was kind of how your sister because
in my household my my dad's a potster so
my dad would say some outlandish thing
we start yelling and that was like
almost his love language and my problem
is i've applied that into all my
relationships and most people find that
horrible you just said it perfectly so
that was the lesson that was my
relationship this year was the lesson
learned was was what if i didn't try
that what if i did something different
um
the thing i learned about myself i'm
gonna do one that's not um
not good so you know there's a lot of
lessons that were like ah yeah i learned
this and now i'm better for it this is
one that like i just learned was kind of
like a shitty thing about me so
i've now had several friends that um
i've considered to be my close friends
or like they worked for me or whatever
like i've kind of mentored them in some
way and then they go on to do like
really great things
but like you know they called everybody
except for me to like kind of like share
the wins that they were having or or let
them on board or to invest in it or like
you know just
i wasn't in the loop beyond once our
once our kind of relationship once are
like once the transaction was done like
once we stopped working together
in my head i'm like oh yeah we're super
tight and in their head they're like
they had a different opinion because i
had
lunch with a buddy and i said he was
telling me about like this crazy journey
he's been on like dude can i ask you
something kind of weird i was like
i've noticed this happening a bunch of
times like you had this crazy journey
and i feel like i thought we were super
close and we're just now talking about
it like i wasn't i wasn't in the loop
like you didn't let me know like you
didn't share these awesome things that
were happening or the crazy bad things
and like you took other investors i feel
like i could have been like your first
check into your thing like i was like is
there something i do that makes you feel
that way and he's like yeah can i get
can i guess what he said yeah go ahead
i just thought that you were too busy
yeah that but like uh
a less generous version of that is you
uh you blew me off basically it's like
it's like yeah like i messaged you a
bunch of times and like you didn't
really respond in a big way so i just
figured like okay he's like he said it
perfectly he goes i he goes i felt like
i figured out what i am to you and like
i thought we were close and you thought
we were saying you thought we were close
but like you made me feel like we're not
that close and like once our engagement
was over you know it seemed like you put
me in some place that like you know you
didn't want to engage as much as i
wanted to and i was like why would you
talk about not me
good old sean no way you know this is
whatever and um and then sure enough i
scrolled back in our dms and it's like
him saying something him saying
something him saying something me saying
one line him saying something and like
asking something and me never respond
never getting back
how do you come back combat that because
like you've gotten very popular
but it's not that it's like well this is
this is the problem this is the problem
is like so much of becoming friends with
someone is where you're at in your life
and how much time you have for the other
person and whether you're in sync or not
so some of my best friends they were you
know we're both single we're both
drinking and partying you're super super
close and then you have kids and life's
different and you kind of drift apart
and the same thing can happen with
texting if they're texting you all the
time and they want you to engage and
then you send a one-liner back they
immediately take offense they don't
realize that you've got 300 other people
texting you and you just want to be
friends with everybody and it's funny
you mention this because i wrote my
worst habit of the year is writing blunt
one-line responses to dms and text
messages because i'm busy right i'm just
trying to rip through them all and i'm
tired but it's way it's way better to
not respond at least then you're
mysterious and oh maybe you didn't see
it the one liner pisses people off so
much
it's a little it's a little better it's
shockingly better if it makes you feel
better sean i perceive you as a person
who's in the loop of everything though
yeah i don't know i i basically i re i
realized my self-perception of kind of
where these relationships were at and
how uh good of a friend i was being back
i realized like oh no i'm actually i'm
kind of a shitty friend back
uh i
i can make people feel bad when without
really realizing it um and and also that
that costs me like that i don't get to
share in the wins and and know the
stories and be kind of
friends and and get these opportunities
that like you know would otherwise have
come from this and so that's once i have
it like five times i'm like okay the
problem is me i'm the common denominator
here
one of the habits that i've realized
there's two things one one is like using
a smiley when you say something takes
the edge just immediately even if it's a
one-liner takes the edge off the other
thing is a friend of mine does this he's
very very busy super spread thin
big personality lots of friends and he
will just every once in a while
text me and say hey man i was just
thinking of you
uh or you know or you know let's say
it's new years he'll say hey thanks for
your friendship this year here's
something i really appreciated or took
from you and it comes across as very
authentic and i've looked at that and
gone okay i need to really learn how to
do that because i'm like you exactly as
you're saying this i'm just nodding
along i think i come across as distant
and cold and too busy and i don't want
to and i just want to make everyone
happy it's so sad
you know bracket first name i was really
thinking about you yeah that's what's
going to come out from us this year
yeah someone listened to andrew
relationships and um learning about
learnings
yeah okay so um my biggest relationship
hack honestly my wife her love language
is acts of service and
it's really interesting like often
she'll start picking at me about some
other thing i'm doing that pisses her
off and will have a fight about
something and it ultimately came down to
the fact that i left towels on the floor
or i left the kitchen dirty and so now
i'm just trying to whenever i have that
moment where i'm like i see the
kitchen's dirty i'm just unloading the
dishwasher and trying to enjoy it and
get it done the other thing
no no no no no i'm not a slob but i
always say to her i'm like what's the
point of making money if you use your
time doing things you don't want to do
right whereas my wife is much more like
i don't want our kids to grow up without
them seeing us work and you know doing
stuff so so we don't really have any
help around the house we have a nanny
but um you know we have a cleaner who
does all this stuff we don't want to do
besides we still do all the shows
we have it's all us no we don't we don't
we don't have any of that we don't have
we're not fancy like you um and then the
school of life uh which they make that
card game i mentioned before i love that
so much that i bought this one called
the connect card game and it's for
couples and my wife and i have been
doing it and it's basically five stacks
and each stack is like you know one is
sex one is like general relationship one
is personal whatever and so you roll a
dice and you go through these questions
and again it's just this great way to
penetrate through
you know you might be in a bad spot but
when you answer these questions it kind
of unlocks everything and
builds connection between the two of you
and that's been really really good for
us because my wife doesn't like doing
the meetings or couples counseling even
a lot of the time but that's been a
great thing for us that's baller
yeah ours are me and your we have the
same thing dude i totally i really
that's cool you said that about the um
people thinking you're a dick or checked
out because i i have that exact thing
and you you said it really nicely uh
yeah it's
kind of it's hard it's hard and you know
i've even experienced that with you and
i've probably done it to you as well but
it's like you know you and i we've
texted and we've had these long
exchanges and then there's other times
where you text me and i'm like one line
yeah or vice versa and it's it's i think
it's one of those things where like i
would i maybe i do take offense i don't
know but like in my head it's like i'm
so i have so much faith in the in the
relationship that i'm like there's not
like
it's not gonna like affect my score you
know in a way um yeah and also like i
hate the kind of excuse if i'm busy
because basically to me when
the phrase i'm busy means i'm poor it's
like if i think wealth is freedom of
time and to be able to spend how you
want then saying i don't have time
means i'm poor and so i'm like i don't
want to accept that that's also reality
so you know i'm trying to figure it out
well it's also there's two i've what
i've noticed is when i don't work with
somebody i text them differently when we
do work together when we work together
it's like there's
total filter i'm not going to be nice
i'm just gonna be super blunt and we're
just gonna grind it out and that's just
business and whatever and not i'm not
being an i'm just being very to
the point but i think that can come
across the wrong way and i i think
people sense a shift they start working
with me and i suddenly become this like
super blunt person
like what happened
all right so i was back okay so i got uh
i got the categories here okay so let's
keep rolling we have i think three big
buckets left all right so we're gonna do
these together so
book of the year and or and then that's
the first one and then the second one to
do is you know a podcast newsletter or a
person you started following you start
subscribing to so a book and something
you started subscribing to that you
really loved let's do uh let's do andrew
first
okay so i read this really great book
that sam i think you'd love called clash
of the titans it's from the late 90s and
it's two parallel stories one is ted
turner and one is rupert murdoch right
from the beginning and the stories are
kind of interwoven and at various times
they clash and uh you know try and buy
the same businesses and stuff um but
it's two different
wacko billionaires so these guys are
both insane in their own ways you know
murdock is like quiet calculating 100
focused on profit uh but very slick and
smooth ted turner's like insane
unpredictable emotional
all about building a brand name uh and
making an impact but it's really about
him
reviews on amazon it
yeah it's like totally weird i had to
buy it in print although i found it on
um audible but anyway it was a really
really great read i didn't know that
much about rupert murdoch before this
and i gotta say he's obviously evil but
uh really amazing um billionaire
business person and that he's been going
since 1957
and he's somehow only now this is a huge
number he's only to us he's he's only
worth 8 billion and you see these other
people who are worth like 30 who have
been going for like five years um so
it's it's uh it's pretty wild but anyway
great great book i met rupert murdoch
once have you met him andrew
yeah you told this story you went to
some symposium or something to get
because it was sharp right amazing
basically what he does is they own all
these properties they own like whatever
wall street journal fox and like a whole
bunch of other things i don't know what
they own exactly but it's like a bunch
of huge media publications
and uh
they're all these different businesses
they're all spread around the world
and he um he gets everybody together
once a year and he rented out the top
floor or top two floors of the wind in
vegas
and he puts all of the ceos of all the
execs basically all the all of his
different properties puts them all up
it was during ces but they didn't attend
ces they were not down at the conference
floor shaking hands or anything like
that they were in his room which is like
the presidential suite or whatever
and um they would just start at 8 a.m
and they would go from 8 a.m to like 6
p.m or something like that and it would
be back-to-back talks 30-minute talks
they would just bring in some some
somebody from some other field
to give us to give a talk and they would
grill them with questions and they'd be
like thank you so much for coming next
and it would be like
um you know the number two guy at
facebook would go yeah you went with
like the skim
this game was they then they have like
three or four startups as well because
it's like before before us or you know
it was like ceo of slack stuart
butterfield went and gave his talk and
by the way talk is like you know there's
30 people in the room or something like
that so it's not like a presentation
it's like just someone kind of
spitballing about what their what they
do in their view of the world
and um and then they get asked a bunch
of questions and so this goes like eight
or nine hours straight
and if you look around the room because
i i got there early and i just stayed we
were talking at the end but i just sat
in and sat in on the whole thing it was
amazing
and i looked around the room and people
you know oh there's the president of fox
and he's his attention's drifting and
this person's you know they own the new
york post and they're they're on their
phone
and rupert murdoch is like the star
pupil he's front he's in the first row
he's you know sitting in the first row
he's
doesn't look at his phone he's attentive
the whole time he's taking notes he
asked the best questions and he had the
most energy like this guy went eight
hours straight he was like 87 years old
at the time he's 90 now i think
and um he's the oldest guy from no
bathroom breaks this guy i don't know
what this guy's going to be since
he's seen succession i've seen season
one and it's so yeah loosely
it's amazing kinda yeah and they like
this old guy in succession
he grinds man he's they're they're like
working like 24 hours a day and it's
always serious and very and
is just like that and when i hear that
i'm like this seems miserable how are
they on all the time they have so much
energy
right
well not only that but rupert murdoch
he's brought all of his kids the reason
succession is based on him is that he's
brought all of his kids in to the
business and then his kids have one by
one failed to become the heir apparent
and fought each other and they all hate
each other and leak stuff to the press
and it's it's really horrible i think
rupert murdoch is a great uh he's a
great way to invert you know what do we
not want i don't want to become rupert
murdoch because it doesn't seem like fun
to me although maybe his personality uh
maybe that works for him i really
respect him uh okay so then you're uh
you subscribed to andrew so uh podcast
newsletter or whatever so uh yeah and
there's not really i i kind of got off
twitter although i've been kind of
getting back into it a little bit um and
i haven't subscribed to any newsletters
at all this year i've just i od'ed last
year the person i um i really have been
enjoying their tweets is uh your friend
nikita nikita
buyer he had a really great tweet
recently where so you know all these
people they do aqua hires to facebook
and facebook basically just buys
companies to shut them down right they
find promising social networks that
might compete with them they go buy them
for tens of millions of dollars before
they turn into anything and they bought
his company and it's kind of like a
prison for entrepreneurs they make you
sit around for three to five years and
vest your stock and a lot of people hate
it and he had this great tweet where he
says oh i'm leaving uh facebook after
three years here's a thread of
everything i learned points down and
there's just nothing there i thought
that was awesome you know he was sitting
on that one for four years as he vested
out he's like here's how i'm gonna go
out
um okay great sam what you got book and
podcast newsletter whatever
book uh i'm gonna go with endurance
story about a shipwreck and then i'll
also go with empire the summer moon it's
about the comanche indians they're just
and and the texas rangers and how they
fought and they're all just
savages the rate
dude endurance is so good and by the way
when i said savages i mean the native
americans and also the texas rangers
they're all they treat each other
horribly endurance is amazing it makes
me feel like my life is meaningless and
soft um and then things that i followed
this year um okay the first laird
hamilton i learned all about him this
year that guy has the ideal life in my
opinion he's surfer businessman pretty
amazing cool dude
the second is how to take over the world
ben wilson's podcast one of the best
things i've subscribed to and i'm gonna
suck up even further sean the the five
bullet for or the uh five tweets tuesday
baby that's freaking awesome i like that
too so those are the things i started
following this year all right love it uh
okay so mine uh book okay i just started
reading this book so this is gonna sound
a little silly because i'm 10 pages in
do you read
thank you
uh
i i dabble i basically have like you
know i'll buy 50 books in a year and
i'll read you know 10 to 30 percent of
10 to 30 of them so it's like i read one
book at the end of the year um
so this one i've read 10 pages so far
and in the first 10 pages this book has
more wisdom than anything i've ever read
and i'm not saying i read a bunch of
wisdom so that's the caveat but uh is
this book called think on these things
it's by this philosopher guy named
krishnamurti
and um
[Music]
i don't know where i think of all maybe
mentioned this guy's name as christopher
murphy and i just went bought this book
it sat on my couch for like you know a
year i didn't look at it and then i just
picked it up one day and 10 pages in
i literally i've reread the first 10
pages three times
and i like i just don't even want to go
on i'm like oh this one principle these
two principles that are in this first 10
pages are so good that if i internalize
these you know my life changes and it's
just amazing
i just i'm looking at it now
sounds awesome i just bought it
yeah i mean i sold it pretty hard yeah
all right so that's that's the first
book uh second uh the thing i subscribe
to this is kind of a again a little bit
of an expected one but i listened to the
all in podcast uh i don't know if you
guys listen to sam i don't think you
like it right or you don't listen i
don't listen to any business podcasts
andrew do you listen i feel like this
might be up your alley yeah i find i
i love i love all in but i found it was
like um it's too stressful the time i
listen to podcasts in the evening and
the last thing i want to do is get
pumped up on deals and what's going on
in tech so yeah i listened to it and
specifically i would actually say david
friedberg on the podcast i actually find
uh the rest of them to be very smart and
very entertaining but very obnoxious to
me personally um like
you know like i'm sure these are they're
obviously successful they're obviously
you know probably you know fun to hang
out with and things like that david's
like the real nerd but he's the real
nerd and he's the only one i feel like
there's never is never presenting a face
he's never virtue signaling or like
building their brand by saying certain
like i think chamoth is amazing but
also i think he virtue signals a bunch
um you know i think that uh you know
jason kind of says he's a man of the
people but uh like i think he's kind of
likes being high class and likes hanging
out with high-class people and doing
high-class
um
but that's what that's what makes it
good is they're all they're they're
they're all like best friends but
they're horrible to each other and
they're all great
and they're all they're all very they're
very complicated personalities every
single one of them and i think that's
exactly it's like a great tv show where
the characters have flaws um and uh yeah
david sacks is super smart but then like
super political and uh kind of
like an extent and he's always just
looking for some story that like
supports his point of view
uh and usually that point of view is
that everybody else is biased but like
you know clearly just
constantly searching for information
about how other people are biased um so
anyways i think that there's i love the
show i enjoy the show a lot and those
characters but i think david friedberg
is actually
the one who uh is kind of like a star
discovery for me this year of like super
smart gives great information about
science and stuff like that
is very balanced and fair in his like
pov um while still being saying
interesting things and isn't i feel like
he's not trying to build his personal
brand and popularity through the through
the show so um
you know to the extent that everybody is
when you create content like i think he
does a good job of not um
and one of the reasons by the way i
criticize those other guys for doing
that sometimes is i do it right you spot
it because you got it it's like
i sometimes will say something that like
i know makes me look good or you know
presents me and assert myself in a
certain way so you know i see it when
other people do it too um
so anyways all in is you know maybe the
thing i i enjoy the new thing a new show
i've enjoyed subscribing to that's great
all right do we want to what was the
last one was okay i got i got two more
so there's this is a quick one mfm guest
of the year so who was the best guest
that came on the pod
and then your person of the year
somebody you really enjoyed getting to
know hanging out with working what about
industry and company that's gonna be the
last one
all right i'll go first uh rob diernick
and ariel helwani for guest of the year
rob dierdick blew my mind ariel he was
the biggest fan i'm the biggest fan that
was a like i'm the biggest fan of his of
all everyone we did and then what was
the second question uh someone person of
the year just your personal your sam's
person of the year who dude i'm gonna
suck up again i gotta say ben and sean
i've been i'm like so we just crossed
like two million uh
listens per 30 days um i think we hit
2.1 or something like that um i'm very
very this is the thing i'm most proud of
that we've done and uh so i would say uh
and and with ben i think we found the
perfect third man
so shout out to
were you tearing up just a little bit
there it seemed like you i've been very
kind to sean and uh like all the people
involved in this podcast where they're
like why are you being so nice i'm just
really proud of of what we've done it's
something i've been very proud of dude
when we went to miami for the live show
so the other bend the bend works me my
my partner he he came with
and he's like i'm finally getting to
meet sam i've heard him on the pod for
hours and hours i've never met him and i
was like yeah he's great and i was like
you know but like hey if sam like gets
like impatient with you or like anything
like that don't take it personally like
you know it's just kind of his style
like you know when he
we're doing a live show he's gonna want
it to go well it might be high you know
high pressure and i've seen him kind of
like go off on people sometimes if like
you know whatever and we get there and
sam was zen sam he was so kind
so thoughtful so nice so happy and ben
was like what the were you talking
about dude i was like i don't know where
this came from this hundred percent
happy sam but like this is amazing and i
feel like the whole i don't know if it's
the acquisition
you know
whatever the working out i don't know
what you're doing but dude you've been
so much happier this year it's amazing
it's part acquisition and and we're
getting the results we're finally
getting we're finally becoming as
popular as i thought we should
you're you're not you're not um
threatened anymore right like before if
the hustle failed or anything went bad
that directly hurts you and you're that
you have safety
right so you're not you're like a dog
you're like a dog you have ample food
now you don't need to
it's just like it's it's been two years
it hasn't been that long since we've
been doing this maybe two and a half
years i forget and it's finally like
coming to fruition and it's the hardest
thing growing the growing the hustle
wasn't that hard growing this has been
very hard
dude i just want to say i'm so i'm so
happy for you because i thought you're
going to sell the hubspot and be out of
there in like three months be bitter
upset you sold your baby and it's so
cool to see the podcast going so well
the hustle going so well trends going so
well all the people still there and you
actually like the guy you sold to that's
yeah i mean i think i undersold so i
definitely have some regrets but i don't
regret it at all and i'm i'm happy i i
intend to do this podcast for a very
long time
investing is a hell of a drug
wait did i go off script
do you the thing you paid me to say
earlier about it
did i have to say about doormat all
right andrew guest of the year and
you're just your favorite person you got
to hang out and interact with
so my favorite guest was um steph smith
is always amazing like i i tweeted this
out but i think it's like she just drops
thousand dollar bills on the ground for
amazing entrepreneurs to pick up there's
just so many great ideas
uh and i think for you guys the best
format is a shitload of quick hits and
ideas and i think she always delivers on
that i don't really always love it when
you guys just interview someone about
what they're doing
the other one i loved was huberman for
that exact same reason just like you
know i got him on your thread right now
you tweeted that you love him and i also
like him and i just said hey andrew dm
me come on the pot it was on your thread
yeah no way oh that's amazing yeah he's
he's amazing he's been my actually i
should have said before he's probably my
favorite podcast subscription i just
love his stuff it's so in-depth
um and then what was the other question
person in your life your favorite person
of the year non-family
uh
so
i would say well i may have talked about
him before but this guy kimia who uh we
started a business with uh last year we
started this negotiation business called
fire with him and i just freaking so
i'll just share basically what happened
so basically he met this guy super
scrappy entrepreneur told me he wanted
to start something and he told me he
loved negotiating randomly in like some
conversation and so i started testing
him i'd be like hey i'm going to you
know i'm buying a nice car can you
negotiate it for me or uh hey we're
buying a bunch of desks for the office
right and the guy would just save me
like 40 on everything and hustle and
he's awesome and so i was like okay dude
this should be a business like
negotiation as a service you need you
know a lease negotiation sas software
whatever so we start this business
called buyer we go 50 50 on it i promote
it and talk about it given the rails and
accounting and stuff and we literally i
think we started it for like 50 or 100
grand and we sold it to ramp about maybe
six months ago now for single digit
millions and so we went from like 50k to
you know single-digit millions in a year
amazing exit for him i would have loved
to keep owning the business but this is
what he wanted to do and it was just so
cool
watching somebody actually take the
baton and then run the marriage
uh and the guy's just freaking awesome
you know i don't know i mean we were we
were already profitable i think we could
have made a couple hundred thousand
dollars of profit in the first year um i
told him i was like look like i think we
should hold this but uh for him you know
as a it was the first time he was ever
going to have a good one like that and
you can't undervalue
uh he's he's working a ramp
so yeah and you just can't undervalue
you know getting a couple a couple
million
jeans right
uh i think it's still i think that's a
great i think that's a i think they've
rolled it in someone should just copy
that yeah yeah it says right here yeah
they've like integrated it into ramp
buyer.com or no buyer. someone should
just do that again i thought that one
had legs
uh if anyone's listening and wants to
restart that business with me because
like i don't think ramp would care like
we would even say like we won't do sas
or something but just i want someone to
negotiate a car or a lease or you know
these big ticket things
you're
you're trying to mine okay so guest of
the year i had uh
uh hassan minhaj i thought he
brought it and uh what i loved about it
was i thought the episode was good but i
love that he genuinely listens to the
pod and uh
like it was a conversation it wasn't an
interview almost every guest is like
they show up cold they usually have
never they've heard about the show but
they never listen to it or listen to one
episode just to prep for it
and um
and the ones who do like dharmesh he
listens to every episode when he came on
guess what he's fire right steph listens
to the episode so she knows the vibe
this was the same now he's not like a
business idea machine
but um man the feedback i got from that
episode of people just being like dude
that conversation it literally felt like
i was in the room i thought that was
something cool that was something are
you guys like homies now
yeah we text all the time and isn't that
funny
what's the what's this story so he
listened and then messaged you or how
did you crazy connect the dot story
actually so there's a another guy who's
a comedy writer for a tv show
his name is azar and he he writes the
show remy on hulu um and so he listens
to the show i don't know how he
discovered it he listens and he was like
dude this is great now his network is
people in kind of like hollywood and
like specifically maybe like brown
hollywood and so he tipped a few people
off to it and and i took like a random
meeting with him you know i have this
one block every week just for random
spontaneous meetings with cool people
that are like
in my orbit
and so i took this meeting with him we
had great vibes we connected great and
uh i think he then told hussein dude you
got to listen to this show
and so then he started listening from
there and then he reached out he dm'd
and was like
my a couple of my twitter threads went
viral like the clubhouse one and then
this other one the metaverse one and
after each one he would reach out and be
like dude that was like that was so good
and one time he just called me and at
the other that was like dude he's like
he's like we got to meet he's like i'm
doing a show in san francisco let's come
and i go great can you uh stay an extra
day and let's record the pod oh you know
really so that's what he that's what he
did he's like yeah he's like as long as
it's in person i'll do it i said great
can you extend your trip one day and
that's what he did he did eight shows
over a weekend and he stayed an extra
monday and then we recorded it
god that's pretty badass isn't that
awesome that's one of the greatest talks
about this another example see this is
this is why i don't understand why
anyone does public speaking like you
look you look at this and you're
literally reaching millions of people
and it's all these random people you'd
never expect to meet yeah when's this
crazy episode is over i'm gonna like
click close and then i'm gonna go like
feed my daughter lunch and like you know
not have to be on a flight somewhere you
know albuquerque to because i gave a
talk
well one of the one of the things i
thought was weird so you talked about
this on one of the episodes where you
said
you know you brainstormed with him
business ideas or whatever
why why would you if he doesn't like
touring like you were like oh yeah you
could tour make all this money but dude
like i think that seems miserable flying
from city to city to city staying in
hotels i would say it's a it's a good
and bad i talked to him about it he's
like well obviously the feeling of like
a live crowd is a thrill and
exhilaration like musicians comedians
athletes are really the only ones who
get that like yeah insane love from
thousands of people while you perform
your best work like that's a pretty good
feeling so that's addictive
it is definitely cool when you're single
too
and the other upside is you make a
ton of money off of it so touring is a
great business model it's basically the
music industry makes all its money off
touring now live shows so touring is
where you can make a substantial amount
of money compared to
online stuff the
the bad the downside is he just had you
know his second kid and you're out of
the home for like a significant period
of time and you know you bring on the
road can get really tiring and your
health blah blah blah
well it's also linear you know you're
limited to the number of people that can
fit in this so i don't know if you did
you hear the idea i gave them which was
to create you know hamilton for brown
people yeah the hamilton i thought i
liked that that's great this is the
winner all right let's do the last two
right last two so the last two is
company to watch and
and or like a prediction yeah crazy
prediction for 2022. so company to watch
for 22 or crazy prediction and or no so
then it's sorry you you're missing one
so it's company to watch industry you
got your eye on next year and then
prediction
yeah something like that yeah you can do
those three all right let me go first
prediction i think san francisco is
going to be cool again
by the way can i read out our
predictions from last year yeah um
because i think we got something wrong
so our prediction for last year you said
san francisco will bounce back continue
to be the center of tech for decades i
said that yeah you said that you go
uh
you said and then your second one was
that pornhub and large companies will
it'll be normal to pay pay subscriptions
for porn uh okay i think san francisco
went down the drain this year so far and
uh i don't i don't know anybody paying
for porn really except for i guess only
fans uh you got that part right
that's huge yeah only fans that's
literally true you got that one um just
not pouring up then san francisco's
still gonna come back i still believe it
andrew you said you said uh no one's
gonna give a about covet in a year
or it's gonna bounce back much faster
than people think and they're gonna
forget about it and i was like yeah me
too i agree with you andrew that was
mine as well i think you're wrong we
were both
that's i think it's true if you go to
the states right now i mean no it's like
everything's open nobody cares about it
it's totally normal not this week the
fact that we've done an entire episode
we're living in a pandemic and nobody's
mentioned anything about it in an hour
and a half right
and then what was the other one uh that
was it so mine was mine was a cop
so andrews i said my prediction all
right company to watch this youtuber
named meet kevin i've been watching this
guy he has a 51 million portfolio and he
reveals the whole thing and now his
business is making 30 million dollars a
year with four employees i think that
sean said one day there's going to be a
billionaire youtuber i think meet kevin
is the guy who but potentially could do
it and then industry that i got my eye
on at home diagnostics i'm incredibly
fascinated with at home diagnostics i've
been i've tried all of them i think a
lot of them are really cool and i think
it's going to continue to boom and i
think it should continue to boom because
we need it okay great andrew what are
yours uh company to watch
um crazy prediction and what was the
other one what uh industry to watch yeah
industry
so um company to watch i mean it's
exciting to talk about all these new new
businesses but what i'm actually
interested in is all these companies
that were incredibly hot like three or
four years ago that raised a ton of
money and and they've been kind of
quietly building so for example
superhuman uh you know everyone was
talking about it two years ago i haven't
heard anyone talking about it but i know
they're doing very well i i can't wait
to see what they do with all that money
uh and then same thing with pitch pitch
was like you know huge two years ago uh
and i think they're in a building phase
so i'm excited to see what they do when
they come out of that uh
pitch pitch.com it's basically replacing
powerpoint it's like a good version
it's awesome
uh well you guys put down prediction or
opinion oh oh this is prediction oh yeah
here we go um i think that uh this high
salary inflation is not here to stay i
think what's happened is all these
companies down in san francisco are
going oh crazy we can hire cheap people
in canada but they're not yet going oh
hey we can hire
people in india and the philippines and
i one of the things i've realized is
that people in india and the philippines
are obviously just as smart but they're
far more motivated and the cost is like
a fifth or a sixth of what a north
american employee is and they really
want the job and they care so you can
either give you know you can pay an
entitled millennial 150 grand or you can
pay someone 30 grand in india and
they'll do a better job and the money
means more to them um so i think over
time i think uh this work will be
democratized across the world and that
salaries will come back i agree with you
i just don't think it's gonna happen
next year
by the way i forgot one one category
that's a great one which i mean
overrated thing thing you are betting
against that other people seem to be
into do you guys have one there
mine was the creator economy
and nfc i had nfts in the creator
economy
and and and web3 image image and
give us your quick why nfts why you're
saying it's the one you think is
overrated most overrated trend right now
well i think um it's
obviously the technology is fascinating
right so that's
amazing um
but i think it's kind of like digital
beanie babies that are easily replica
replicatable at least a baby baby is
kind of hard to replicate these are just
like images that you can download that
anyone can use and i think that over the
long term they'll be really cool once
there's a standard so if every metaverse
or every app uses one api and everyone
agrees that this is the way to access
images or whatever and it's verifiable i
think that'll be incredibly cool and
powerful and i love the idea of like
taylor swift saying like hey i'm selling
you know my song rights to my my fans
and whenever anyone transacts i get 10
10 or whatever that's amazing um but i
just i just think right now it's all
half baked and all the protocols are all
made up and won't exist in five years
and i think i'm going to win our bet
okay
remind reminders ten years right five
years or ten years uh what was the exact
bet yeah
we we have a bet i believe you chose a
piece of digital art and you said it
would be worth more in the future and i
said it'd be less yes um great yeah okay
so i have uh all right company to watch
uh i have a company called um
uh
terra which is terraform labs they've
created something called luna so
one of the biggest challenges in crypto
is that people are like oh bitcoin it's
cool but like it can't be used as a
currency because it's too volatile
and the solution that the cryptic
community came up with was something
called stable coins
and so stable coins are super important
they're you know billions and billions
of dollars are transacted every day uh
you know whatever i don't know about day
maybe it's a month uh using stable coins
with significant volume
and there's a stable coin called luna
that i think is um
the stable coin is called us
ust uh but luna is the the token that
backs it and i think luna has been on
this tear it started the year at you
know maybe a dollar it's at currently
you know 100 so it's about 100 x in a
year uh it's been a great investment for
me and i continue to believe that that
it's gonna work interestingly it's
actually being used in the real world
which is one of the other criticisms of
crypto so
in korea in mongolia in a bunch of
different places um
people use uh this stablecoin without
even knowing that they use it so they
just use their mobile app to pay they
don't realize it in the background it's
being done on these uh crypto rails and
so there's an app in korea called chai i
think it is that has like a few million
users payments app that uses um
uses this stablecoin uh as the as the
thing underneath it so it's it's the
company to watch i think in the next
year because if you can actually crack
the stablecoin use case uh you know
bitcoin cracked the store value use case
became you know fifty thousand dollars a
coin right now going up ethereum is the
you know programmable network uh it's
the compute layer it cracked that and uh
you know four thousand dollars a token
last year it was at like 200 so that's
been an amazing investment and luna is
the the number one contender right now i
think for stable coins and so i'm
keeping an eye on that okay and what are
the others uh industry i got my eye on
is actually vr so uh most people think
vr is just dead or doesn't work but
i don't know if you guys know this but
oculus outsold xbox this year um so
oculus sold 10 million units which is
about 4 billion in revenue for facebook
on just the hardware for getting the
games in the app store that they have
now xbox had some production shortages
so probably would have been more but
like just to round it up oculus did
about 10 billion uh sorry 10 million
units and playstation did 14 million so
it's like it's not that far behind um
do you
do you remember when um oculus or sorry
when xbox had that like weird little bar
that you could put over your tv and you
could like move your hands connect right
that was a huge bestseller right but it
was still gimmick like i bought one
everyone thought it was cool and the
exact same i remember i played it for
like a day and then i was like whatever
this isn't ready and i did the same
thing i've bought an oculus every single
year for the last three or four years
and i every single time i feel sick and
uncomfortable i feel wide awake every
time i use it it's cool and then it's
every time i use it every time i use it
i say to myself it's not there yet but i
i i buy it i buy into it i think apple i
think apple's going to do a couple of
signs i think apple is secretly the
industry of vr there's a couple signs i
think are really promising one is that
over 60 games made over a million
dollars on the platform which i think is
pretty impressive and six games made
over 10 million dollars so i think
that's also pretty impressive uh growth
there so i think vrs is something that
most people are thinking is
it's not happening and it's growing like
rapidly so i thought that was pretty
good and then um
let's see what's it crazy predictions
uh okay my craziest prediction is that
the winklevi
uh
the winklevia end up richer than zuck so
here's the case of how the wink of us
get their revenge in the end oh my god
they own about one percent of all
bitcoin in circulation
they also own gemini in exchange that's
probably valued at somewhere between 20
and 30 billion dollars they own one
percent of bitcoin they want one percent
of all the bitcoin they also own a
substantial amount of eth they haven't
announced how much
and uh if crypto actually like
has its like you know its heyday and
bitcoin goes up to so here's the here's
what you need to believe i don't think
there's a 2022 bet at all this is more
of like a five-year bet
but if you think that facebook is peaked
and facebook you know um doesn't grow or
even maybe drops you know 15-20 percent
uh in value
and um because they're priced at a very
as a growth stock
and uh if you think that bitcoin gets to
500k eth gets to 50k gemini ends up
going public they will actually be worth
more than zuck who's worth 130 billion
dollars today and i think that that is
just a crazy
you know the sequel to the social
network movie is that these guys
actually end up uh you know wealthier
than zuck in the end um so that's my
crazy prediction should be hilarious all
right that's good and then oh my my
overrated trend by the way like my
overrated trend is spax so uh
you know in the last 10 years but 10
years before you know the spec trend
there was like i don't know i think it
was like 40 billion 45 billion of spax
total in like 10 years
then last year there was 80 billion so
doubled it doubled and this year there
was 160 billions i doubled again and if
you just look at spack performance like
um just if you just take chamath specs
chamatu i think you know really started
this trend
year to date i think his average is he's
down 30 year to date and did he make
money off that yes he made a ton of
money
yeah that's people guaranteed money this
is why it's messed up
they all you make you make the money in
the matter
you know heads i win tales you lose uh
setup uh i don't really like it and
that's what happened here is that the
sponsor the promoter makes money either
way
and uh you know his stocks are down his
his stacks are all down 30
and the the overall s p500 is up up 30
so you know it's a massive you know
massive delta there
um
so i think that's you know i think spax
are the overrated uh trend or the thing
to uh the bandwagon i don't want to be
on uh if you're not the promoter i don't
think it's a great place to be right now
how does that make you feel andrew as a
specker
well i'm not a spacker i don't wait
ecommerce wasn't a spec
no no no bloomberg misreported us as a
spec we we did something called a
reverse takeover which is kind of like a
spec but instead of having a spack where
the sponsor gets 20 they're getting like
point zero one percent of your business
there's just these little shell
companies so no we're
a promoter not
on a typical spec uh it's like a hundred
million dollars right
20 of whatever they raise
so
i don't know 20 of the the future
company so if you have a billion dollar
company you're literally saying i'll
give you 200 million dollars to take me
public and the math on it is it with a
spec you can show projections which is
really really valuable for a growth
company and it's a little more flexible
and the timing is a little shorter
you get to show your fancy projections
yeah whatever you think the future looks
like
and you i think you only have to buy in
for two or three percent but you get 20
so that's your spread as the promoter
you pay two percent of the price and you
get twenty percent i don't know about
house packs exactly but it's something
like that
all right this is a good episode i think
ben what do we think
well uh this it was a a long one but i
think it's gonna end up being a hit was
last year's a hit yeah last year was a
hit
yeah i wasn't here for last year but um
i thought this was really great what was
that you mentioned this really cool
podcast sam what was that one called
again
how to take over the world baby how to
take over the world
if anything it's the best intro music
i've ever heard
yeah there you go um no it was a great
episode um
my first time attending it but andrew
brought the fire and uh
the predictions were like a little
a little predictable i will say that um
but other than but the recommendations
the companies the products were all good
[Music]
you